All right, welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
This Q&A, we're going to go over some questions
that were sent in via email and reminder of everybody.
Send in your questions via email
and we'll put them on the beginning of this Zoom call.
So it'll be recorded.
And they are question and screening tests,
question and hypothermia, several on that.
And then lesions following mastectomy.
So let's jump right in.
So the first submitted question was,
what is the difference between the HCG test
and the uncle block test?
Well, first of all, I'm not going to go in
to describe what the uncle block test is
because it doesn't exist anymore.
So the uncle block test was actually
that whole lab was actually bought out by a lab
that started the IBG test.
And the reason why the uncle block test
kind of went out of business is because it just became
very expensive.
So the last I heard it was going to be
in the two plus thousand dollar range
to do a test and it was just basically
pricing themselves out of the market
because it had to be manually read
by basically a PhD scientist.
So it was very difficult to read, very accurate
but it became cost prohibitive.
Same thing that's kind of what happened
to the IBG test,
they're back to research and development
to find a home fully or less expensive test.
The HCG test is the one that many of our patients do.
You can find that on our blog posts,
so also called the Navarro test.
HCG stands for Human Coriota, Good Antitropin Hormone.
And you can find that on our blog post.
So it's instructions on how to do that.
Is the HCG test used for discovering cancer
and monitoring it?
Yes and no, the negative of the HCG test
is that it's not specific.
So if you have cancer in your body for any place,
it's going to show a positive over 50,
but it's not going to tell you that you have cancer
in your liver or cancer in somewhere else.
If you already know you have cancer,
the value of the HCG test is similar to doing a tumor marker test.
So a tumor marker test is going to be a blood test
that shows an elevated tumor marker.
There's multiple tumor markers.
We went over that last time I did the Zoom call a couple of weeks ago.
And it doesn't tell you that you have a test basis.
It just tells you that your cancer may be more active.
So if the HCG test is elevated
from the last time you did the HCG test,
that tells you that your cancer may be more active right now.
So it doesn't tell you that the test aside,
doesn't tell you, it did metastasize where it metastasized,
doesn't tell you what type of cancer you have.
So if a person doesn't know they have cancer
and they're just doing a screening,
they feel like maybe they have the same symptoms
their mother did when she had cancer.
Could they do the HCG test to find out if they have cancer?
Yes and no, according.
It's not a clear lab and it's in order to legally die
of those cancer, of course you need to get a biopsy.
See, it's still, but it can be a screening thing to know,
wow, that's elevated, I need to go in
and get some investigative journalism done on my body
and figure out what's going on and where I have cancer
maybe gonna biopsy or whatever.
And then as far as monitoring,
if you know you have cancer,
you do your first HCG test, let's say it's 51.5,
then you could use that as a monitor
when we'd forward if it stays at 51.5.
That's a good thing, typically that tells you
that your cancer's probably not progressing
and that's a good thing if it goes down,
it's even better, but then if it bounces up,
then you might want to do some investigation
where it is getting more aggressive or possibly spreading.
So you could use it for both discovery and monitoring,
but legally to diagnose you need a biopsy, hopefully that helps.
Next question, what's the best heat therapy
for helping the body rid itself of cancer,
specifically lung cancer?
So heat therapy we're talking hyperthermia,
hyperthermia increase heat.
So heat hyperthermia increases the metabolic rate,
it's a nice little chart,
it increases generation of reactive oxygen species locally.
This is where oxidative stress can be a benefit
if there's cancer that is there.
And then it increases oxidation
and then the oxidation can help kill cancer cells
so that it can be very good.
Well, what do we use for hyperthermia?
What do we use as a source?
This is the benefit of Saunas, we'll talk about that.
This is the benefit of using a hyperthermia unit
like we use in the office.
What is the best hyperthermia unit?
So this is a continuation of that question,
is an infrared heating pad okay to use with lung cancer?
Well, an infrared heating pad like this,
and this is a good infrared heating pad.
This is the ones we have in our office
and I have it in my home and the ones I use.
You could get these on Amazon,
they're $140 or something like that.
Are these good little units?
Yes, there's good little, these are good little units
but they're not gonna really increase the body temperature
very deep.
So they might advertise that they go down four centimeters
or something but the temperature rise
at that is probably pretty small.
If you really are looking,
so the studies that are out there
of using hyperthermia to really kill cancer cells
are you have to use a true, far infrared
like the one that we have in our office,
the Cleveland clinic was doing some experimentation
with micro wave.
That is of course much deeper than true, far infrared,
but it is very damaging as well.
So it has to be very controlled,
but they did some testing for using that with breast cancer
with very good results.
The danger is it's similar to radiation
that it kills healthy tissue.
With true, far infrared,
you can never kill healthy tissue with it.
So there's no downside as far as that goes,
no side effects of it, but the downside is
is that it has limits to the depth.
So all the things that you could use have limits to the depth.
This has limits to the depth.
You have to be careful with these type of shitty pads
because you can burn the skin because they're not true
infrared.
This similar with a biomet, it's a biomet,
be good, they tell you it penetrates five to six inches.
It doesn't penetrate five to six inches
with the level of heat needed to kill cancer cells though.
Same thing with a heating pad,
you don't use a heating pad to kill cancer.
You're not using a biomet to kill cancer,
no matter what they tell you.
It's just, I just don't believe it's happening.
So biomets are great.
They're good to increase circulation.
Heating pads are great.
They're great to increase circulation.
Increase circulation in your lungs
if you have lung issues, congestion, lung cancer can be good.
You have to be careful because they increase circulation
will increase inflammation as well,
which can be good for cancer.
But if you have a space out to probably lesion
like a big tumor in the lung
when you're putting heat there
that's actually increasing inflammation,
increasing the possibility of more space out to probably lesions
that is fluid, you've got to watch the person closely
to make sure they're not having more issues
with breathing, adding heat.
Even the infrared that we use in our office
that goes deep, the true foreign infrared,
that's why it doesn't, you don't see it in light
because it's below the light spectrum completely,
because it's a true foreign infrared,
it still doesn't go deep enough to go through the ribs.
So when you're dealing with lung cancer specifically,
you have to go through the skin, through the tissue,
through the muscle layer, through the ribs,
and you're just not gonna go that deep.
So the unit that we have as far as killing cancer,
quote unquote, goes really has to be a surface cancer.
Breast cancer is where the research is done on that
and that's where those units are used in Japan
is really with breast cancer.
Could be good for a skin cancer as well,
some sort of surface cancer, it can be good.
With these kind of units here with the heat pad
and with the biobet you do have to be careful
of trying to put it on the skin to kill cancer cells,
I would never say that that happens,
but you'd be careful about murder yourself
because you can burn yourself with those units.
Compared to an infrared sauna,
you're just trying to raise core body temperature.
Now even with an infrared sauna,
even though there's studies with these type of infrared
sauna that you do, you can raise core body temperature up to,
even up to 101, there's a couple studies that show,
even up to 102.
You really need, if you're really gonna do cancer killing
with hyperthermia, you need to get the core body temperature
even higher than that, like 103, 104,
and even higher than that.
That's what you really need to really kill cancer
if you're trying to raise core body temperature.
So the benefit of external unit, superficial units,
like the one we have in the office,
if the cancer is close to the tissue,
you close to the surface,
you can effectively help the body kill cancer cells.
Or, so there's an all of what hyperthermia,
or if you're thinking of using something
to raise core body temperature up,
you can effectively kill cancer cells.
But really, we talk about sauna to really detoxify
not so much kill cancer cells.
No, some of that might be going on.
It's really hard to get that deep core body temperature raise.
And that's what you really need.
So to answer this long,
we didn't answer to this simple question here,
is what's the best heat therapy for ridding your body of cancer,
especially for lung cancer?
Really, there isn't one.
So the lungs are deep in the core of the body,
and you're not gonna be able to get a heat source that deep.
So you could use heat therapy and use sauna therapy
to help detoxify and that would help using heat therapy.
I like using like a hot pack like this over the liver
to help decrease the viscosity of the bile
that helps the liver flow and the gallbladder flow
and help move things through the liver more quickly.
So indirectly, you're helping a person with cancer greatly.
But you're not gonna really be able to get a heat source
of any kind that's gonna be deep enough
to penetrate the ribs into the lungs.
Same thing with like abdominal cancer, prostate cancer.
It's, you're not gonna be able to get deep enough
to effectively kill cancer.
So the, hopefully that answers that question.
Next question.
I had a double mastectomy in April, 2020.
Not sure when they first appeared,
but I have very large area around the incision.
On the left side, this is not a picture of this person.
I just pulled these off the internet.
The side where the large cancer is tumor
was removed with numerous raised red bumps.
It almost looks like hives, but in some areas
they all run together.
So I kind of pulled the picture off the internet
and how it might look.
I do have to ask that patient who sent this in
for their own picture so I can look at it,
but I didn't wanna put that up there if I had it.
I have been applied topical CBD cream
twice daily since my surgeon expressed concern
about this area a few weeks ago.
He referred to them as lesions.
I understand anything on your skin
or in your body when you look at an x-ray
that is not supposed to be there is called lesion.
So these are lesions.
I noticed the bumps, but I thought they were scarring
for this incision, that's a possibility.
I now see that they go beyond the incision area.
I think the surgeon suspects cancer
as he wants to do a biopsy of one of the lesions.
Stop there.
I think it's a good idea to do a biopsy of one of the lesions.
It's not uncommon to have cancerous lesions
show up after a surgical removal of a cancer,
whether it be the surgical removal of the breast
or internal surgical removal debulking of a cancer
and you get cancer again at that spots.
Very common with prostate cancer.
You remove the prostate and then the bed
where the prostate was becomes cancerous.
That's not uncommon.
Good idea to do a biopsy of a few of those.
Other than the right machine and current supplements,
are there other recommendations that we could do?
I've read that black Sam is good for tumors,
but not sure.
Black Sam might be, this might be an application
possibility for black Sam who wrote this,
please call the office and we should chat about it.
Black Sam has some other things that you need
to be concerned about and deal with too.
I've also started doing castoral packs of my liver
as my billy Roman numbers were elevated.
This is why you would do heat packs over your liver.
Billy, Roman levels elevated are a good side
that there's some stasis in the liver
and you're not getting the bile moving
through the bile duct and into the gall bladder.
So doing castoral packs or at least just hot packs
over the liver are a great idea.
But the question goes on, could I use castoral packs
over this issue?
I would not do castoral packs over this at this point.
Give the office a call.
This question just came in today.
Give the office a call and we'll talk
about possible solutions for this.
We don't want to jump to conclusions at its cancer
but you want to jump to a conclusion
that you need to do something about it.
We need to take a closer look at that.
All right, we will end our recording.